because the republicans have what would
appear to be the most winnable election
maybe in my lifetime that they've got in
front of them but there's this big wild
card there is this big elephant in the
room a big lion in the room if you ask
me
mr koffe himself donald trump will trump
run or not
if you believe the polls take them with
a grain of salt of course
trump
does not do very well against a democrat
against joe biden or other democrats
compared to other candidates who've been
floated such as ron desantis
again that may be true that may not be
true i don't believe those polls at the
moment i just think one it's too early
and two i don't i don't really trust the
libs uh when they're when it comes to
donald trump in particular because they
hate this guy and the fact that they
hate this guy so much is one of the
reasons that i like the guy so much a
liberal magazine new york magazine just
did an interview with trump and
according to the magazine they seem to
suggest that trump is going to run in
2024.
the the interviewer asked him when are
you going to make a decision and he said
i've already made my decision
that's done i've already made my
decision
but again that's kind of ambiguous
does that mean he's decided he's not
going to run but he's going to keep
leading people on to believe that he's
going to run so that he can maintain
some influence in the party what but
then later on in the interview the
interviewer says he kind of loosened up
and he made clear he is running and he
said the only question now is do i
declare before the midterms or after the
midterms
again the way i'm reading his literal
words i think he still leaves himself
some ambiguity
but if people were taking bets today i
it would be
it would be very hard to make the case
that it seems like trump is not running
he is doing and saying
everything that someone would do or say
if he were running for president and
he's got every reason to run
he feels he was jilted the last time he
didn't get to complete his second term
he's still extremely popular he's
leading the field by what 40 points now
the only thing cutting against him is
his age and i know it's popular now to
say that
older people should not run for
president i don't i don't think there
should be an age cut off elon musk
recently said no one over the age of 69
should run for president and i think it
was mostly because he wanted to make a
joke about the number 69 but i don't
think that's true i think it's entirely
dependent on the person ronald reagan
famously said he's not going to make age
an issue of his campaign and he's not
going to exploit for political purposes
his uh his opponent's relative youth and
inexperience ronald reagan was the
oldest man we had ever elected president
and he's one of the best presidents in
recent american history and so it's
entirely dependent on the person joe
biden is now the oldest man who's ever
been elected president and he doesn't
know his own name and he doesn't know
what end is up so i think you've got to
you've got to make that calculation not
based on some arbitrary number but on
the man and if you look at donald trump
love him or hate him the guy is still
totally with it he's still totally full
of energy he's campaigning like a much
much younger candidate even now he's
going out and campaigning for midterm
candidates and he he was he was asked
about age during the 2020 race and he
said look
listen i don't know if biden's too old
i'll just tell you i am so young i'm a
young vibrant man and he he acts that
way i don't know if it's because he
doesn't drink i don't know if it's
because he's mostly aspartame and fast
food preservatives now but i don't know
if it's good genes whatever it is the
guy is very energetic and if he runs he
seems
likely to win the primary i don't think
it's inevitable i think if a desantis
ran or if a different candidate ran i
think they would have a chance in the
primary but again just looking at the
numbers just looking at the name
recognition just knowing the candidate
if trump runs
he's very likely to win the primary
and so if you don't want trump to be the
nominee and if you feel that trump is
going to lose the general election
all of your energy has to be focused
right now on stopping him from running
for president
and i know there are a lot of
conservatives who
either they hated trump then they like
trump that they hate trump again or they
liked trump from the beginning but
they're sick and tired of trump or they
really like trump but they think look
trump's just not going to win
re-election so we got to move on to
somebody else
i am open to all of these possibilities
i am not committed to any particular
2024 primary outcome right now i know
some people have already picked their
horse i have not i say let the chips
fall where they may let the process play
out i really really like trump he's my
favorite former president alive today i
love i love desantis desantis is the
best governor around today i like a lot
of other candidates who potentially
could throw their hats in the ring from
other segments of the political order i
say let the process play out but you are
seeing that primary already taking place
and the clearest place you're seeing it
is in the feud between trump
and elon musk right now go to ring.com
knowles summer is here you're probably
going to be away from your home for long
stretches of time though even if you're
in your home you want to be safe no
matter where you are you want to protect
that home the physical home your
property your family your digital home
your data that's why you need ring
everyone knows about rings video
doorbell where you get to see and speak
to whoever's at your doorstep from
wherever you are in the world a lot of
people know about ring alarm that is
rings award-winning alarm system not as
many people
know about ring alarm pro you got to be
a pro baby when it comes to security
when it comes to your home your stuff
your family of course you got to be a
pro be like me become a pro cnet calls
ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security because you're monitoring not
just your doors and your windows and all
that stuff you're also monitoring your
digital home your data we spend so much
of our lives in the digital virtual
space you've got to protect that you may
not have known about it but it is true
ring has an award-winning alarm system
this busy summer season protect your
home gopro with ring alarm pro learn
more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
the primary for 2024 for the republicans
is playing out not with snipes between
trump and ron desantis or snipes between
trump and ted cruz or tr snipes between
trump and mike pompeo or nikki haley or
whoever
the the 2024 primary right now is
playing out between trump and elon musk
why people are saying why why are these
two
social media genius billionaires why are
they going at it because elon musk is an
avatar for ron desantis
the the elon trump feud
has
been
just continuing in recent days and
elon has said about trump
i don't hate the man but it's time for
trump to hang up his hat and sail into
the sunset dems should also call off the
attack don't make it so that trump's
only way to survive is to regain the
presidency trump would be 82 at the end
of his term which is too old to be chief
executive of anything let alone the
united states of america and then
here is where even with all of that
trump would probably snipe it at elon
but here is where trump felt he had to
snipe it at elon
elon said if desantis runs against biden
in 2024 then desantis will easily win he
doesn't even need to campaign
now i dis i disagree with that
perception not because of any weakness
of desantis just because of how corrupt
the liberal establishment is
so i i agree with elon musk desantis
would be i think a phenomenal candidate
no question about that he's a phenomenal
governor but would he wouldn't even have
to campaign i don't buy that for a
second i think they would they would do
the same thing to desantis that they did
to trump that they did to bush that they
did to reagan that they do to all of
them and they'd say he's a nazi and he's
a rapist and he's a racist and he is a
pedophile and he
he probably punched his grandmother in
the face you know they would they would
throw the kitchen sink at him
so trump now is punching back at elon
the reason he's punching at elon too
it's not even it's not even just about
desantis
it's about anyone saying anything nice
about any republican candidate other
than donald trump trump at this moment
knows that he's on the top of the heap
he knows that the nomination is his
basically if he wants it
and so he's got to make it very painful
for anybody to endorse any other
candidate he's got to make it very
painful for anybody to boost or raise
money for any other candidate whether
that's ron desantis whether it's ted
cruz whether it's josh hawley whether
it's rand paul whether it's nikki haley
whether it's
pompeo whether it's whoever
that's what this is about
and it's unclear right now
could
could ron desantis
or someone else but desantis seems to be
top of the heap right now could he mount
a successful primary campaign against
trump
i'm not sure
i'm not sure
right now i lean toward
no
but maybe that could change desantis has
been on a rocket ship of success and
name recognition and goodwill in the
republican party recently maybe he could
maybe he couldn't but one thing i know
for sure is republicans want to avoid a
bloody messy primary contest between
desantis and trump especially because
trump fights so dirty
they don't want to see the golden boy
governor of florida who's doing such a
great job destroyed because of this
bitter contest for president
now it gets even more interesting than
all of that
because of a figure not in state
government not in the federal government
not a former president
because of a tv show host
a tv show host
who is just
just for some reason going to be taking
a trip
to iowa
so this show has come to iowa for a
couple days giving a speech at the
family leadership summit in des moines
lots of people who are running for
president are swinging through iowa we
thought we would assess the field we're
going to stream that speech live on fox
nation tomorrow friday 5 p.m eastern go
to foxnation.com for access tucker is
such a pro the guy is so smart
listen to those words which were
scripted those were in a teleprompter he
chose those words very carefully he said
we're swinging through iowa
our eyebrows go up
he says yeah i'll be given a speech so
it's not just that he's doing interviews
it's not just these covering it on the
ground he's giving a speech to an
important conservative summit our
eyebrows go up even further
and then just in case anybody missed
what he's putting out there he said
lots of people who are running for
president
are making tours through iowa right now
giving speeches that sort of thing
and then he gives himself the out a
little plausible deniability he says so
we're just here surveying the field
oh we're just here doing journalism
but i'm also giving a speech
and i'm giving a speech with the other
people who are maybe running for
president
a lot of people have called for tucker
to run for president i think he could
mount a pretty serious campaign not
saying he would win the nomination
necessarily but he could mount a pretty
serious campaign and then it occurred to
me
he could mount possibly the greatest
campaign in the country
for vice president
especially if trump is the nominee
if trump is the nominee who is he going
to pick for vice president obviously
it's not going to be mike pence
guess it could be
could be ted cruz
i don't know again yeah it's a little
awkward because i host a show with uh
senator cruz i have not spoken to him
about this at all this is just purely my
own conjecture but i i guess i could see
that
the united states senator so it kind of
balances things out uh nikki haley i
could see nikki haley worked for
donald trump she brings in a little bit
more of the moderate side of the party
though she did irritate some trump
voters when she went after him in
politico but then she kind of she said
that this didn't represent my actual
views about trump and so i don't know
she might be able to do that
maybe i don't know maybe a pompeo i
don't think a desantis really could i
just think desantis and trump are too
similar they they have they've had
roles that are too similar in government
their personalities are a little bit too
similar i don't see desantis taking a
vice president i don't i don't see trump
offering it to him but
tucker that
there's a lot of ideological overlap
between the two men
they come from totally different parts
of politics trump from
from the executive from actually being
the president tucker brings in the media
he's the most popular conservative tv
show host
and yet there's a lot of overlap there
too between the guys
both have a big background in the media
world trump really respects guys who
come from the media trump endorsed dr oz
i think primarily because dr oz had a tv
show
just very interesting stuff i don't know
exactly what's going to happen but
that could be
there could be a kind of natural
spot if tucker wanted if tucker went
crazy and wanted to give up his
extremely lucrative very influential
post on television to go join the melee
of elected politics i'm really glad you
liked that clip i need a favor i'm very
close to 1
million subscribers and if i get a
million subscribers i will feel like a
very very cool guy so i need you if you
have not already subscribed click that
bell just subscribe ring it get the
notifications if you have already
subscribed just copy the link to this
channel and send it to all of your
friends every single one of them tell
them to subscribe we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you